[Music]
welcome to another episode of not too
deep i'm your host
grace helbig today we have cami crawford
with us who is
absolutely stunning inside and out you
might know her as a former miss teen usa
or a current co-host of mtv's catfish
she's just
so lovely we talk about the world of
pageants her experience there
what was helpful what was hurtful now on
to her
hosting one of the most popular shows on
tv
catfish and what she's learned about the
world of catfishing because
it's still happening more than ever and
there's a lot to learn
she also is extremely passionate about
voting and gives some really great
perspective on why
as a young person it is so important to
vote and the things that you should be
really considering when you do i had a
great time talking to her i learned a
lot
um also just the mutual shared love of
home goods
there's a lot of home goods talk so get
ready for this episode of not too deep
with cammy crawford
[Music]
cammy thank you so much for being here
um i do
feel like i'm instantly transported to a
catfish episode you are
that's what this is welcome thank you
um so they won't face time but they're
for sure real
so right all good typical
well also uh los angeles is still
relatively new
for you right yeah i'm two years in now
okay how's how's that experience been i
mean you've had some
uh a range of experience in two years in
los
angeles with everything going on right
now oh yeah i think i've gotten like the
full scope
of what to expect uh from the angelinos
but i
love it here i'm from the east coast i'm
from maryland
um and before this i lived in new york
for eight years so
this is like completely different but it
was like the
change that i needed to see in my life
good
yeah yeah that's awesome um well let's
go back to the beginning
um i'm from new jersey also fellow east
coast
um i want to talk about let's talk about
first
obviously uh miss teen usa let's go back
to those years how did you get
involved in the pageant world
it was kind of by accident i was just
in high school i was a senior was i
senior yet or junior
who knows it was so long ago five
million years ago
um but one of my best friends had
competed
the year before i did and she was just
like
i did this pageant last year it was
really fun i feel like you would really
like it
you should do it you'll make cool
friends and it'll be fun and i was like
okay
sign me up like i'm down for fun and
then
you know i got fully immersed
in the pageant world which is
a whole entire thing on its own that's
that there needs to be a constant
reality show based around pageantry
all the time that's what i'm so
fascinated by
it and for you to have like how long did
you actually spend in that world
i mean that so i competed at state
that october i think she might have told
me about it in like january or february
okay i competed in october i won miss
maryland teen usa on my first try and
then after that you have to go to
nationals and i won
miss teen usa so it was only about like
a year's
worth of time but i mean i got i got my
full experience
i'm sure you got my t-shirt yeah
because uh i read that you were trained
by miss pennsylvania
yeah so loren marilla stranger now she
was
one of my walking coaches then i had
luciera who's another
like famous pageant and model walking
extraordinaire she's the one who
taught kendall jenner how to do her
model walk on that sort of keeping up
with the kardashians
she's an expert and then i had
you know i had two interview coaches i
had
jules who's like my pageant fairy
godmother who has her own
pageant um consulting company and
she trained me on like paperwork they're
so you have to know how to walk how to
talk how to
you know do everything it's a it's an
entirely different
world it's kind of like training to be a
princess of disneyland like you have to
know the ropes yeah i mean it sounds
because
i think people can write it off very
easily from the outside not knowing
on the inside what it's like so the what
kind of
training you kind of said so you go
through walking training you go through
talking training i mean they're like
making you into a different person
almost it's like yeah it's like it's
it's
it's the grace of being a princess of
disneyland but like
the brainpower of being a politician
like yes
very you know there's there's only so
much growth happening within the pageant
industry as much as i wish that there
could be more
but you know you have your fitness
coaching you have
and that is it's not like just your
regular regular fitness you're not just
going to soul cycle and like calling it
a day like
everything is like lean lean you have to
make sure that your muscles are lean
everything is like
small and then you have your interview
coaching which teaches you
how to interview um and you know
answer questions in 30 seconds or less
yeah but concise but also like you know
put in your point of view wherever you
can
and then you know you have your
paperwork which is
you know when you go into your interview
at miss teen usa or at any pageant you
have an interview portion of the
competition because we don't have
a performing talent portion of the
competition right so
everything is pretty much interview
based so you learn how to answer the
questions
how to do it in a short you know little
time span
um and for your paperwork everything
that they ask you is based off of the
paperwork that you provide so if you
have like
your grandma do your paperwork for you
and
you know your grandma writes she loves
chocolate and dancing
and then you get in your interview and
they're like so what's your favorite
chocolate
candy and you're like i hate chocolate
i'm allergic yeah yeah
it will kill me if i have it that
happens
all the time i can't tell you how many
times that happens
don't think about it interesting and so
i mean i was watching your stories
because by when we're recording this
this will go up later we just had the
vice presidential debate last night
and it must be so fascinating for you to
watch
through the lens of all that training to
see how they're answering questions i
mean what's that experience like
i mean for me for me
i think coming from a pageant background
but now working as a host and like
having that training on top of that
which is completely different because as
a host you have to
you know connect with the person on the
other side of the lens
who's watching you so for me i focus
more on like the moderator
who i'm like where's the follow-up like
yeah this is what the people want to
know we want to like
make sure that this person answers this
question like don't just
let it pass by so you know for me that
part is like the most frustrating but
then
you have the whole entire aspect of like
the president of the united states used
to be my boss
yes so
well one of the um like the
you had a tweet in like 2016 that was
extremely informative and i think
confirmed a lot of people's
suspicions about the um terribleness of
the human being that is
currently our president that said donald
trump doesn't like black people so don't
take it the wrong way if he isn't
extremely welcoming towards you is what
someone actually said to you
that's wild to me yeah i mean
i was 17. i had
no idea that i knew that racism existed
obviously but i had never experienced
anything firsthand
um and even with sharing that experience
i didn't think that it was going to go
anywhere like i just was you know i'm
always on twitter like i'm just talking
about things that happen in my life like
that's like a normal thing
yeah and it was right before the
election and i was just like you know
what
people keep on saying like donald trump
has done so much for black people i'm
like okay
let me let me explain something to you
okay or they're like
he had a black girlfriend in 1994. i'm
like
okay like what does that mean you have
black
children and still be racist it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter so i tweeted it not
thinking
anything was gonna happen and then i got
a call from my mom like after midnight
asking me well not even asking she was
yelling she was like
cameron why is inside edition calling me
on my cell phone at midnight what did
you say what did
you do and so i was like i had no idea
and the next thing i know was on like
cnn and
msnbc and i wasn't expecting any of that
i wasn't doing it for any of that
yeah um but you know it's important that
people are properly informed and like
i think that the most harmful thing
that's going on right now is that people
are just
blindly following and listening to
anything that they hear
like yeah you can't do that i i love
barack obama with like every fiber of my
being but if he makes a mistake
i can acknowledge when he's made a
mistake and that's that's the difference
yeah i think
um when you refuse to acknowledge that
someone that is leading your
group of people um that they are flawed
in any way that
becomes a cult and that person becomes a
cult leader and those are just i don't
know
the factual things that kind of happen
in that regard uh that's the way it is
yeah but that is i mean
incredible and also like you know that
your intentions are good and then all of
a sudden this thing blows up and you're
like oh my god
now i'm responsible for some sort of
movement around this this is
wild um where
in your uh the beauty pageant world did
you like
make a conscious decision to formally
like step out of that did that did you
stay in that world for a little bit
i don't think i ever had a choice
because i
am so vocal that i mean i'm like the
black sheep of the pageant family
like i just i don't give a [ __ ] like i'm
gonna say what it is that i feel like
i wasn't in the world long enough to you
know be silenced or feel like i have to
silence myself and i know
way too many girls who are you know a
part of the industry who feel like they
have to
always be politically correct and they
have to always
you know appease one side over the other
so that they don't get bashed
i really don't care i'm getting bashed
since i was
16 which is when i started competing i
have
you know seen the worst of the worst
i've been called the worst of the worst
i've had death threats i've seen it at
all like there's
nothing and that was just from competing
in the pageant
because i was the first black winner in
a decade
so i saw it all and
nothing phases me at this point like you
know even
with having a show on television right
now and working on that show
you get negative comments and people
always like how do you deal with that
i'm like if i can deal with the pageant
people
oh i can deal with anybody 100
do you still watch pageants now
or are you kind of no my mom
was um the executive director for miss
dc usa and miss connecticut usa so she
is kind of the person who puts on the
state pageant but then
gets the team together to train the
girls for miss usa and miss teen usa
oh cool so i was super involved with
that when she was doing that
um she had three national title holders
in like four years which is unheard of
and they were all black
the current miss teen usa is her current
girl and she had back-to-back
black miss usas from the same state
which is like
not even a thing yeah she's
like incredible but she was kind of the
person
in you know for for black pageant girls
my mom was really the person to show the
industry like
this is what you're missing out on when
you're not giving our girls a chance
because there are so many states that
still have never crowned a black
contestant
because they just don't want to or they
don't believe in it
and so um you know when she was doing
that i was super involved with
her process but other than that like i
have some friends who still compete and
i
you know it's great like i'm always
going to root for them and
i think that there are a lot of benefits
and
cool things about the pageant industry
but i think that there's also a lot that
needs to change
and you know yeah what would you
change or hope to see kind of evolved in
that world
one thing in particular i was actually
talking to a friend of mine who we
competed together at miss teen usa
um we both made the semi-finals and she
was talking about we were talking about
like our weird relationship
now with fitness and she was talking
about her relationship
now with food from competing in pageants
because
you know even for myself like i just
started with a new trainer
this is the first time in my life that
i've felt like i'm going to work out
just to be fit
and strong and like feel good and not
like i'm going to work out because i
need to lose weight and i want to lose
weight and like that's or i want to be
lean and skinny and small
that's never something that i've ever
wanted for my life but
being in pageantry and like you know
that kind of fitness and grinding your
mind you think that that's like the
normal way and it's
it's not sustainable um so we were
talking about that and i was just like
when are we ever going to see a girl
that's over a size 4
compete on a national stage at a pageant
like when is that going to happen
because now
i think it was what a few years ago miss
canada was competing at miss universe
and she was considered like
the curvy plus-size contestant she was
probably a size four
wow like how what what's so unrealistic
yeah yeah and what does that teach
women who are watching like this is your
plus size contestant you know like it's
it's
it's it's really wild and that is
something that i would love to see
change like obviously
fitness is a huge part of pageantry but
there are plenty of girls who are fit
that are a size 10 or a size 12 or
what have you like it fitness doesn't
just come in size zero to two
right yeah and there's it's interesting
and i think one of the reasons
i'm really fascinated in that that world
still exists today is that there seems
to be a little bit of contradictions of
like
putting forth you know the most
confident and you know whole
person that can represent a certain um
you know intelligence and awareness and
compassion and blah blah blah
but at the same time you have to conform
to this ideal
like old school weird confining terrible
standard
for yourself uh completely it's
it's pretty nuts and i i'm with you i
hope that that kind of like
uh expands a little bit because uh
there do seem to be like benefits like
what would you say were the biggest
benefits for you
in having gone through that world i
think the biggest one is
i wouldn't have ever explored being on
television
had i not competed in the past really
because at the time i wanted to be a
dermatologist i was like
fully on the pre-med track like i was
like get me out of here so i can start
my 12 years of school i got a lot of
[ __ ] to do
yeah so even while i was missing usa and
like living that life
i was taking the train like 45 minutes
to up to westchester new york um
and going to manhattanville college and
like starting my prerequisites that i
could get those
done so that when i started my freshman
year of college
i could start the pre-med track that was
like where my mind was
yeah so i was exhausted
for like most of the time
it's a lot it was a lot um and
you know from that experience i got a
lot of on camera
you know training and work and and you
know
going to different events and being
asked to do like a little quick
spot on you know a show or you know
something something small
and like hosting a segment and that was
kind of what even put it in my mind that
i could be good at something else
and that i should try something else
because i think you know when you're a
kid and your parents are like you're
you'd be a great doctor yeah
okay that's what i'm gonna do
yeah so it kind of you know just showed
me that i could have
another passion in life and i think
that's like the best thing that i got
out of it
totally it expanded your perspective a
little bit
um okay we're gonna get into all the tv
stuff
in a quick second we're gonna take one
quick break and we'll be right back with
more not too deep
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to hosted by me
grace helbig
just wanted to say a couple of things
one thank you
so much for listening and two if you are
enjoying yourself to such a degree that
you'd love to leave
us a review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be and that was my
couple of things now back to me me
okay let's get into this new endeavor
you're the official new co-host of
catfish
on tv that's so exciting let's talk me
through
how this even came about because i was
watching episodes where you were guest
hosting on him listen i was talking
about this before you came on
and it's like you're so natural on the
show i also
have a voice of the audience of just
being like come on what the [ __ ] are you
doing
right now and it's great it's so
like uh you can breathe a little bit
right and i appreciate that
because that i mean that is my biggest
thing when i'm watching tv that's what
i'm thinking
like why are you saying what we're all
thinking yeah
thinking you sound nuts like say that
you know
and also this show has been on for years
and you know
the premise isn't going to change every
episode but you do
find very unique things about different
stories
so yeah how did this come about for you
so it was two years ago i got
a email from someone at casting or said
they were
casting for a production company one of
those
in catfish i i mean like
you're in the industry i thought it was
[ __ ] i was like
there she was like hey we would love to
have you come on and co-host a few
episodes of catfish i was like
huh i have been working in this industry
for seven years at that point nobody
just emails you and it's like hey do you
want to co-host one of the biggest shows
on television as a guest and like
come on for two episodes right so i
thought it was complete [ __ ]
but i was like you know what let's see
where this goes
it's like i'm into it whatever i mean
how ironic
is the idea that maybe you're being
catfished by
someone in the industry that you're like
i know against my better judgment but
i'm just gonna see
so that's why i see how it happens
because
it could happen to me easily i was also
in a weird mind space because
i was going through my quarter century
life crisis
if anyone knows that is like the worst
part of a person's life
oh yeah it'll hit you really hard
triggering and very traumatizing and
scary
and i was also in the process of packing
up my entire life in new york and moving
to la
with no real plan of what it is that i
was going to do so my mind
was on fire
in the worst way like everything was
burning down around my brain
and i was just like this is fine like
let's let's go let's talk about cabbage
so
i spoke to her on the phone she ended up
being
um a former pageant girl herself oh wow
knew about me and i guess some people
from mtv were following me on instagram
and i had no idea
and she was like we would love to have
you come on and close
an episode or two if you're into it i
feel like you'd be great like
let's do it so i was like yeah sure
let's do it so then you know
i waited like a week and then she was
like we're going to send you your travel
information you're going to iowa city
tomorrow morning and i was like yeah
sure whatever i thought oh i thought it
was a lie
i still thought it was a lie i'm packing
up my apartment with my mom and my
sisters and my boyfriend
and they're so excited they're like
you're gonna be on catfish that's so
cool blah blah
and i have been a long time fan of the
show since the documentary so i know the
show
i know i know it's a big deal
but i'm thinking it's all lie and i'm
like
[ __ ] it i'll go to iowa so i get on the
plane i'm on my way to iowa i'm
literally
like in first class with a glass of
champagne in my hand and i'm like this
is
to be a hilarious way a lie when i get
there and it's this is all [ __ ]
yeah i get to iowa i meet the production
i still think it's a lie yeah you're
like i'm on
punk'd actually and this is how they get
me yeah
i'm like i'm living in a simulation and
none of this is real
so the next day they give me my call
time i walk in this room
i'm in there like eating the crafty
because they had a spread
i'm like if i'm gonna be here i might as
well smack yeah let's see if these are
fake
that was that was my mentality neve
walks in the door
and i i probably spit out my apples
like i was like oh
my god this is real then my heart rate
just like
shoots through the roof i start sweating
oh god but i'm like wait so they have
they have cameras rolling and they
haven't prepped you for this at all
no they thought it was cool they thought
it was like they thought i was
cool with everything i had no idea that
this was like my actual reality
so i'm just like play it off play it off
this
no everyone's fine but you have like
five cameras on you
and me who i've been watching on my tv
for like seven years
is walking towards me oh my god and
luckily like after the initial shock
and disbelief wore off a little bit we
got right to work
and it was seamless after that like
there was just no
it's it's to me never felt like work
still doesn't feel like work like it's
just a fun thing that i do with my new
friend
yeah i mean i think that's what makes
the show
so successful is that you guys
aren't approaching it from like you know
cognitive behavioral therapy experts or
like
you know fbi investigators or anything
you're just like real people deducing
real
facts in real time for people exactly
that's so wild to me that there's no
formal like rundown of here's how we're
gonna do it
so you basically like trial by fire like
learning
while you're in it yeah yeah how was
that first episode then because you
literally got
thrown into it as soon as we started it
i was like
this is what i want to do this is the
show for me
and i i called my mom immediately after
and she was like
literally i don't think that there could
be a more perfect show for you because
when i moved
to la i had other ideas in mind at this
point i hadn't even moved because
after we filmed that episode i think i
flew back on a
sunday night and by monday morning at 8
a.m
the movers were coming to pack up all my
stuff and ship it to la so
it was just crazy how things worked out
because i had no plan i didn't know
what i was going to be doing but after
we filmed that up so they were like we'd
love to have you come on and do two more
and then they were like we'd love to
have you come on and do two more and
then we'd love to have you come on and
do two more
and then they asked me to be the
permanent co-host
and i was like yeah this is this is my
life
this is what we're doing it's so cool
yeah and so you were
using social media and do and like you
know building
a brand and voice online before all of
this
how has this affected the way that you
now
view or handle your social media
um i think i mean i'm i'm definitely
not any more or less cautious than i was
before
except for the fact that you know i've
always been
a person because i am vocal about a lot
of different things that if i'm posting
like on my stories when i'm out and
about i don't post in the
in the actual time happen moment i wait
until i leave and then i'll post and if
i have to post a location i'll post it
after i'm gone
very safe yeah
um and you know i get messages from
people all the time like i think i just
saw you walking down
hollywood boulevard i'm like huh
what was i doing wasn't doing anything
terrible yeah exactly
that's always super awkward but other
than that like
i i have always loved using social media
to connect
with people who you know support me
people who don't sometimes those are
always interesting conversations
but i i i love social media like i think
that
it's great i think that there's a lot of
people that use it for you know
negative uh reasons but
i'm not one of those people so i just i
like to make my social media a safe
place to have like
educated discussions and um
just to like talk like i i think
one of the things that i was complaining
about just the other day is like
influencers which i am one
not talking about real [ __ ]
i'm tired of talking about your favorite
lipstick
that's great tell me your favorite
lipstick but also tell me about like
things that are happening in the real
world that we can all benefit from
hearing about yeah i think that's really
i
truly admire how uh outspoken
you are i'm not even outspoken just
spoken about
things that are going on and your actual
opinions about it in a way that seems to
invite everyone else into the
conversation with you like you're
creating dialogue with the people that
are watching
or following and i think that's hugely
important because a lot of people are
very
image conscious and very worried about
you know
which i'm sure mirrors a lot of like the
pageant world
a little bit and so it i think it's very
cool
that you are you're still exactly who
you are
even though you're hosting this tv show
because i'm sure a lot of other people
would have
restrained themselves a little bit on
being so
um voicing any opinion that they have
about anything so i think that's very
cool that that's something that you do
think people should do more of
yeah i think maybe the ptsd from feeling
restricted for like a year and a half
as a beauty queen coming out it's just
almost exploding
seeping out of my pores i just i
i feel like a fraud if i'm just sitting
on social media
looking cute and not talking about you
know issues
that affect my life yeah i feel fake
there have been times even during this
quarantine then i'm like why the [ __ ] do
i need to post a selfie right now people
are dying
like who cares about my face right yeah
you know
unless it's like look at this face but
also click this link to you know
register to vote or something like that
it's just to me you know we can have
we can make social media a frivolous
place we can make it a more meaningful
place
where we can actually have discussions
and you know i
i like to open things up for my
followers to be able to ask questions
and not feel um judged or anything like
that because i think that that's part of
the biggest issue people don't get
the answers that they need because
they're too afraid to even ask the
question because
they don't want to come off as any type
of way or you know get bash for even
asking the question but
how are we going to learn if we don't
ask
questions yeah a hundred percent i also
i think one that's great because you're
you're also telling people that you're
not
fully informed but you are constantly
educating yourself and that that
is the process that you have to go
through
also just the the ability to balance
like this beauty side
with a side that is aware of and
uh wanting to talk about what's
currently happening
in the world i think for a lot of young
girls especially
they feel like they have to put on a
beauty face or something and that
that other side they they don't co-exist
with each other
but yeah they do absolutely they should
why shouldn't they and i feel like
if a brand doesn't want to work with me
because i'm speaking out about
you know injustice or things that affect
my life and my body and
the the lives and bodies of my friends
and people that i don't know and the
people who support me then
bye
somebody else will want to work with me
and you know they'll probably pay me
more so it's fine like
exactly i think for every person that
unfollows or doesn't want anything to do
with me
i have hundreds of thousands of new
people every day who are coming in that
want to
learn and you know appreciate the things
that i say
totally and i think it's great too that
you are showing young people
that an interest in politics and
interest in what's going on is important
and cool
and not overwhelming because a lot of
times i know for myself when i was
younger i didn't want to be
as involved because i felt insecure
about not knowing anything that was
going on and feeling the overwhelm
do you have a particular issue or reason
or thing that you think young people
should
get involved in politics for like why
people should care about voting why
people should be
excited and eager to do that especially
in this
[ __ ] crazy time that we're in oh my
god
i can only come up with one i have so
many i think
for me there's there's so many
yeah so many last night i was talking
about reproductive health and
reproductive rights and
that is something that i think that any
person with a vagina can relate to like
i'm not gonna have some old dusty fart
telling me
that i can't take birth control if i
need birth control i have been on birth
control since i was 13
not because i was having sex but because
i have
painful periods i have dysmenorrhea i've
had it from the beginning
i know people with endometriosis are
people with you know
ovarian cysts and things like that that
have to take birth control
because it regulates our organs and if
you don't have that organ
why are you making decisions about that
organ you don't have it
mind
so that's one thing um another big thing
you know for me is the climate like i
i'm not the most you know recyclable
green
girl on the planet but you know i have
my glass straw
i try to do what i can when i can but it
scares me that like
my children and grandchildren may not
have a planet to breathe
on that that is scary so you know if you
care about that maybe some young people
aren't thinking about kids but
i'm going to be 28 this month and that's
something that
concerns me now is you know i'm thinking
about that but also
i'm going to be 28 i want to have
children and
what's that going to be like for me if
someone else is in charge of
you know my body how does that you know
affect things and
i was actually talking about that on my
stories last night and i got it
a message from someone who was um
planning on voting third party
okay which is a whole other conversation
um but she was like i i don't
like trump i don't like biden i was
gonna vote third party but after your
conversation about
you know body autonomy and you know
reproductive rights i am absolutely
voting for biden because
you're right like that is that is right
and i'm like this is why we have to have
these conversations
yeah absolutely people don't know what
their plans are
you know if a woman has a miscarriage
which most
i can't really name a woman in my life
that i know that
has never had a miscarriage if you have
a miscarriage and you have the
possibility of being jailed for that
because your child dies and it's not
even under your control like what is
that
yeah it's insane it's backwards
i know this is not too deep but [ __ ] you
gotta get deep with that because
it's like well that's the thing i think
that
and yeah this was not too deep but i
it's like you said it's the undeniable
like need to be talking about this stuff
because one
a lot of people will avoid it because
it's uncomfortable and so by default
they're
uninformed and making decisions from an
ignorant place
and then two people read headlines and
take it for full truth without doing any
investigation or in any
further uh exploration of like the what
this really means
for like their lives right in their
potential children's lives
it's especially with you on the climate
stuff because it's not even
a conversation that people are having
like in the debate it's
so like thrown away that i was like wait
a minute we have to go back to this
[Applause]
like lgbtq plus rights that wasn't even
touched last night and that is something
that is on the ballot
and i i have friends who identify as
queer i have friends who are trans i
have friends who are non-binary i have
friends who are gay i have friends who
are straight
i have friends who are the entire
rainbow
and not on the rainbow at all and you
know as someone who considers myself to
be
you know an advocate for lgbtq plus
rights it's important to me to hear
the moderator but also you know kamala
harris who i love
dearly call out mike pence for the fact
that he believes in conversion therapy
and everything else like that's
important to me
i want to know that this is being
discussed i want to know that
they're being seen just as much as
everyone else
and you know so that is that's another
big issue that i think that
young people especially can agree to
because we're not our parents or
grandparents generation like we have a
way more open mind
and if you think about the fact that
your friends who identify
as queer or trans are not going to be
given the same rights as you and are
actually going to have their rights
taken away
to even love who they who they love or
or use a bathroom that
you know makes them feel safe that's
something that you should be fighting
for
yeah that's something that i want to
fight for 100
no i think that's great i think uh
you're doing a
amazing job by like making sure that
people that are following you understand
that these are
conversations that should uh be
happening um okay we're gonna take one
last break and when we get back i have
some internet questions for you we'll be
right back
we're not too deep
[Music]
okay cammie before we get into these
internet questions i'm going to ask you
the two questions i ask every single
guest that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most like to throw cold spaghetti
at oh
oh my god cold spaghetti
does it just have to be that i mean
up to you you can decide to heat it up
you can add some sauce to it whatever
you would like
i don't want to heat it up unless it's
scorching hot
um
god alive are dead my god
i know the pressure i'm thinking of so
many different people that's the problem
we also understand that the answer to
this question can change on a regular
basis it can change five minutes from
now
it's just who in this moment probably
that um tommy lorraine whatever the [ __ ]
tammy to me to lee
whatever she blocked me on twitter wow
what an honor
yeah i know i was like don't do me any
favor sis
because i told her to keep beyonce's
name out of her [ __ ] mouth
and i still stand by that and that was
three years ago and i one thousand
percent
stand on that every day for my life i
love to throw cold spaghetti at her
oh i love that i love that that was
three years ago this woman has been a
mess forever
okay the other question is to tell us
your worst pant [ __ ] story
or some sort of bathroom close call but
you can only use three words or three
small phrases
so for example mine is college
jogging front lawn
yesterday home goods
1000 i literally have it in my group
chat with my sisters i was like
i almost [ __ ] myself in homelessness now
it
was bad it was really bad
and that's home goods is one of those
places where sometimes they have a
bathroom and then sometimes it's locked
for employees only
and uh i had a card full of [ __ ] and i
was like somebody's gonna steal
all my pillows if i just leave this card
out but you know when your stomach like
gives you that first initial yep and
then it gives you the second warning
yep and then the third is not a warning
yeah the third is this is happening go
now yeah i ran i ran with my cart
yeah it's uh i feel like i've been there
before too because i just get so excited
when i walk into home goods because
there's so much uh possibility
that my like a child that like pisses
himself at disney world i'm just like oh
my god
there's so many sconces that's me that's
me i have a whole entire
pile over here of home good stuff that i
i got for my
for my balcony i'm so excited i'm gonna
get off of this i'm decorating
oh i love that well okay that bleeds
into this question
um someone's asking how do you practice
self-care and love
in such a busy day ooh
i think for me and i know my followers
are going to come
running to this because they have asked
me to give them
a skincare tutorial for the longest time
but skin care
is my self-care so i think sometimes
you know where i'm like okay i should
film this i'm also like actually i think
i'm just gonna use my quasar by myself
just for me this is me
tags i love like oils i love like the
whole entire
you know 10-step process that i do
that's something that you know means a
lot to me
especially during quarantine like that
was when i really got into like
facial massaging and you know it it
really helps
yeah and home goods is definitely uh
self-care for me i don't care if i buy
anything like if i'm just in the candle
aisle sniffing around
yeah that's good for me oh yeah i've had
days
when i uh first moved into my place a
couple years ago where i had gone to
like two or three different home goods
in one day just to see the other options
that they had
yes yes i was visiting my cousin
um in vegas just
what was it like two weekends ago and
there was a home goods like down the
street from her that was a four-star
home goods and i called my boyfriend
i have to be back by a certain time
because i have a chiropractor
appointment but if i don't go to this
four-star home goods
i'm never gonna know true happiness i
have to see
just cancel the appointment and just go
and
i went and it was fabulous i didn't buy
anything because i didn't mean any of
the things but i was like
wow this is my fight you got to get that
experience that's
so funny um someone wants to know the
most
uh unexpected aspect of co-hosting
catfish
question mark the most unexpected
aspect yeah
i mean other than just the original hey
here you go camera's rolling let's do
this right exactly
other than being the co-host um the most
unexpected thing i think
is how attached i get to the people who
come on the show
um i am like an empath just by nature
but yeah when you know especially when
we were doing the traveling episodes
like we're spending
three or four days with these people in
their habitat like where they live
and you know you really get to know them
we get to know their families we
spend time in their homes like these are
you know very intimate
it's very intimate and we also hear
a lot about their lives that can't make
it on air because of whatever reason
legal
legal reasons sure and so you know after
we rap
i'm thinking about these people for like
weeks i'm like
how so-and-so like did they ever get
that cat that they wanted
that's i'm like so attached and i'm
always following up and like trying to
you know
just make sure that they're okay yeah
you know that first episode that we did
in iowa
um it was rachel and vance that was my
first ever episode
and i found rachel on twitter because
i'm a stalker
and i just dm'd her i was like how are
you how was your sister
like did she get to nursing school
see i would watch that follow-up series
of you sitting down having like a candid
conversation about where they're at now
exactly i just think that it's you know
it's important like i
i i love the fact that we're able to get
people's stories and like have them on
the show but i hate the fact that it's
like we do
it and then we have to leave like our
production people are really amazing at
you know following up and
they have like everyone's numbers in
their actual cell phones that they use
every day
so if people need to get in touch with
them they can but you know for me
my time with them pretty much ends after
we
finish filming right um and so you know
i hate that
yeah that must be difficult yeah um
someone wants to know relatively same
has there ever been
a catfish that actually shocked you
i think they're all shocking yeah i mean
that's the crazy thing when you think
about
when you think about how long this show
has been going and you're like how can
they possibly still
like reinvent their own wheel on this
and then you see some of the
storylines and you're like oh [ __ ] okay
exactly
um i'm trying to think
like does it have to be on my episode or
could it be
any episode that i've ever seen i would
say any episode if something sticks out
to you
there was an episode i wasn't on this
one but the catfish said
that she was a um
oh my god what what is the word
what is the word for someone
who talks to people on the other side oh
like a medium
medium okay why did i just forget that
quarantine
is like rotting my vocabulary you're
good
all good so like someone they could talk
to people on the other side
yes and she she the medium of the medium
the catfish was a medium
and she said that she was talking to
this girl's father on the other side and
that she needed to get in touch with her
because the father
was like very adamantly trying to get in
touch with her
and that to me was like the spookiest
weirdest like yeah and it gave the girl
so much hope
obviously because like you know that's
your father like you
of course you want it she wanted to talk
to him yeah and
i still don't know if they even
confirmed that she was a true medium i
think some of the stories that she was
saying were adding
up but some of them weren't yeah and
that was like
one of the wildest things i've ever seen
because i can't even imagine if i was in
that girl's shoes right how i would feel
yeah i mean
it's the way people can
manipulate other people is
sometimes just so extreme that you're
like of course how would you how else
would you respond to a person coming out
of the blue saying your dead father is
talking to you through them
like that's nuts exactly um
someone wants to know a couple people
ask this have you ever been catfished
yes really but not by a romantic partner
oh okay i was catfished by
a close friend of mine who we had been
friends for over a decade
we lived together like we were
close close okay she
a very very very long story short she
lied to me about literally every aspect
of her life
she faked an engagement she like they
were so there was so much wow so much
[ __ ] she would
she faked so many things i can't even
like begin to
to to list but like for example it got
to the point where like
she was telling me that she was
traveling to all these amazing places
and she would be like oh i'm in i'm on
my way to dubai with the fiance that
didn't actually exist because it wasn't
a real person
um i'm on my way to dubai i'll call you
when i get there and then call me on
dubai
time zone and be like we just landed
i just saw so and so at the airport like
i'm gonna go to the mall tomorrow i
think i want the ceremonies back
and then like it was wow so specific
very very specific
sociopathic behavior is very strange wow
so then you obviously have a much deeper
connection to the people that come
on the show than from experience yeah
i like to think i'm a very good judge of
character
and like i'm a scorpio so my intuition
is very on point but with that one
i had no idea and like the fact that it
fooled me
yeah now i look for every detail and
everything
and you know but it's like when
someone's your friend or or even for the
people who come on the show like when
you
really love and care about someone even
if you haven't met them before
yeah you trust them like we have a blind
trust just by nature i think most people
unless you've been
hurt in a certain kind of way that makes
you not trust people as much
so you know i get it
yeah oh my gosh that's so nice yeah and
it's like
you you have such a a positive and sweet
attitude
towards people until something like that
happens and you're like how am i
supposed to trust
people again why did you do this to me
nobody
trust nobody
uh someone wants to know what is it like
doing catfish from home
they say that they're teaching preschool
from home so basically the same thing
yeah yeah same thing i mean i
love the at-home episodes like it's
super fun except for the fact that like
i have to make sure my house is spotless
every time
you film in here because god people
notice
everything everything people notice
everything i found out today from one of
my friends
who's in like a private peloton group
that
a picture of my bike which isn't peloton
it's soul cycle it's like being
circulated
in group and they're like coming from
catfish has a pellet on they're like no
she doesn't she has a soul cycle bike
she's a trainer
what the [ __ ] like what is this i have
to hide everything i have to hide it oh
and it's impossible obviously because
like i live here but i love
i love the at-home episodes because i
get to do them in sweatpants like i'm in
right now
hell yeah and it's very easy um but at
the same time i do miss traveling and
like
those things are obviously fun and i i
enjoy the moments that we get to have
alone with the people that we're helping
camera and on camera which we don't
really get as much
now because everything is through zoom
yeah i mean it's still incredible that
you guys are able to produce episodes
all while the world is the way it is
yeah
it just shows your catfish doesn't stop
also i'm a little concerned that like
catfishing and maybe you've noticed or
maybe you have
it if it's like picked up more in the
quarantine i can only imagine that it
probably has
yeah for sure because everyone's on
dating apps so people are you know
doing the most yeah and i know that like
tinder now has a photo verification
uh feature that they're doing um which i
think is amazing i think every app
should do that but like
you know people just want somebody to
talk to
yeah very true uh someone to know what
is your favorite reality show other than
catfish
everyone who knows me knows that i am
so into television oh great
you're in a safe space here yes i would
love
to have a show like being a commentary
person for every show that's on
television
my favorite show to date reality show
wise is love island
you can't go okay see that's the one
that i haven't gotten
into yet because i know it's gonna be uh
it'll take all of my time girl let me
tell you something
so good i've never seen the us version
and i do want to get into it
but i have seen every season of love
island uk
i've seen two seasons of love island
australia and mind you
these are hour long episodes and there's
like 60 episodes so i've seen
like 60 hours worth of love island uk
from
one season oh my god and i watched like
five so i'm very much into that that's
like
so like at the time when i was really
like
knee deep i was speaking in a british
accent just for you know
i was thinking in a british accent
that's how that's how much i love the
show
now um would you ever
go on a reality another reality show
that wasn't catfish
i had a docu-series on bt called effin
fabulous
um a few years ago it was only six
episodes and they were like 30 minutes
long but
great show love cool um but
i've always envisioned myself going on
like
big brother wow really that's intense
but i am such a personal space person
that i probably
would actually have a mental breakdown
on television and
like i would be in the like little
confessional room like what may not
happen
yeah which i think would be very
entertaining to watch
oh i'm terrified but also very
intrigued by the idea oh yeah i mean
that's one i could never do because i
know for sure i would have a breakdown
and i don't know if i could recover from
it
yeah that's my concern uh
okay last question for you any tips for
body positivity
there are so many i think yeah one of
the biggest things
that people always ask me is like how
did you become so body positive
and i you know my family is from jamaica
so
the idea of beauty and like standards of
beauty
in different places is different and i
really appreciate the fact that
that was what i got growing up it was
never like if you gain some pounds it's
not like
you know you're the ugliest thing in the
world like that that was just not a
thing
in our household and we never talked
about our bodies in like a degrading way
ever my mom didn't my sisters i have
five sisters
we never did like that's just not how
we were raised to speak about ourselves
it was always very like
affirmative and like loving towards
yourself and your body
um so i feel very blessed in that regard
but when it comes to body positivity
like you only get
one body why are you why are you
feeding it negativity like give yourself
some grace like allow yourself
the [ __ ] french fry if you want the
french fry but when you start to feel
sluggish and when you start to feel
badly about yourself that's when you
know you need to make a few changes
and adjust like that's just how it is
you know during quarantine
who knows what i've gained i didn't care
yeah i was thinking about
what i was eating i'm trying to stay
alive yeah i'm trying to survive
okay survive so if it means i'm gonna
have
you know whatever i want if i'm gonna
have two large cheese pizzas
then that's what i'm gonna do because
that is what brings me joy in this
moment that sparks joy for me so i'm
gonna do that
i love it when it stops sparking joy
then you have to start making some
adjustments so just you know i don't own
a scale
in my house at all i go by you know
based off of
how i look in the mirror how i feel
about myself when i look at myself naked
in the mirror which i think not enough
people do
and you know how i feel like if i feel
gross then i probably need to get my ass
on my bike or like
you know go do something so i think
i think that people try to make body
positivity in like
into this thing that has to be like
it's a strict box and it's not it's just
loving yourself enough to give yourself
the
the grace that you deserve to to be able
to just
live and be happy with yourself
it's very simple yeah yeah it doesn't
have a size number on it or anything
like that i don't even believe in that
like numbers do not define how i feel
about myself if i feel confident and
strong as a size
10 and i feel confident and strong as a
size 2. that's
that's how i feel and i'm happy with
that
i think that's absolutely wonderful that
have a
real open and gentle dialogue with
yourself
that isn't harmful yeah because they say
i mean the
the phrase too that it's like treat
yourself the way you would treat like
your best friend like you wouldn't talk
to your best friend the way that you
talk to yourself in your head sometimes
exactly that concept seems so simple and
basic but i think it is really profound
when you remind yourself in the moment
that that's what you're doing
yeah i read something once it said like
you talk to yourself more than anyone
else in the day
make sure you're saying nice things to
yourself like it's very simple even when
it just comes to like your
mental health and you know just
appreciating yourself for being alive
in here is like so powerful
like just appreciate yourself for
existing
and like even being able to have a smile
on your face during
rough times and if you need a burger
get one who cares
i can't wait for all of the self-help
books
and the spin-off series oh so wonderful
um cammy before we wrap up completely uh
we like to give a little gift for all of
the guests that make time for us and we
have a personalized fortune cookie
that i believe melissa may have emailed
to you
if you're able to open the email
there's a point zero zero zero
zero one percent chance that the love of
your life is
the one who reached out blindly on
facebook the other day
uh-oh their picture is of a hot model
they refuse to facetime and won't meet
up in person but we really think this
might be the one
fingers crossed i'm terrified i haven't
checked my facebook messages
in five million years yep that's for the
best
i don't know what the [ __ ] could be in
there i'm not looking
thank you for the gift cards cammy thank
you so much for being here now for
people that don't know where can they
find you online where can
or when can they watch catfish all those
good things so catfish is on wednesdays
at 8
7 central on mtv and
you can find me on instagram twitter at
cami crawford
facebook i'm not really on there so much
because of [ __ ] like that it's scary
but instagram and twitter all the time
awesome thank you so much for being here
thank you i could talk to you for six
more hours about everything
but uh make sure you're following her on
all social media i love your insight i
love your commentary
i love your hair routine skincare
routines when they happen the skincare
will wait for
but thank you so much again we'll see
you guys next time on another episode of
not too deep
goodbye too deep too deep too deep
not too deep not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music